hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
this is Ike behind me and this is Tamra
Jessa and tonight I went to saw a quiet
place I have crazy fingers because I'm
going as the purple great fairy from
breadth of the wilds tomorrow at c2e2 in
Chicago so I don't normally look like a
football fan is there any football teams
with these colors it's very bright do
you ever say to yourself man I'm
stressed right now I wish there was a
movie I could watch to just relax
my chill out de-stress it's not not care
about something deeply well I've got the
film for you the most relaxing film of
2018 a quiet it was so stressful
I've been real stressed the last few
weeks and this was just like Tamra my
heart was just like yelling at me like
Tamra stop why are you here Tamra Tamra
stop but I couldn't drag myself away
because the movies excellent I have been
looking forward to seeing this film
since I saw the very first trailer for
it whenever I go it's one of those
concepts that you kind of put yourself
inside which I do with a lot of horror
films you're like what would I do in
this situation would I be somebody who
died or would I be somebody who lived
and you really do in this one like what
would I do in this silent world where I
couldn't make an noise at all and it's
terrifying Ike agrees as well it's he
loves it I'm not gonna do any crazy
spoilers there are a few things I'm
going to expand upon that you saw in the
trailer you know for instance that and
one scene one of the kids knocks over
lamp and then monsters are attracted you
also know that emily Blunt's character
is pregnant and has a child in this
crazy scenario of a world that they are
living in first of all i want to talk
about the acting it was so crazy good
Emily Blunt and John Krasinski Jim from
the office are married in real life and
I was in an uber on my way home to film
this after seeing the film and my uber
driver was like oh my god I want to see
this so bad
you want to know how
blunt got cast I was like well she's his
wife I mean I feel like it was like oh
like a perfect matching up he's like
okay so they were trying to find it
because John also wrote help wrote and
directed the film as well as started so
they were looking for emily Blunt's
actress before it was Emily Blunt
and no one was really hitting it super
hard as the uber driver story goes and
they were on a flight Emily and John and
he fell asleep and she started reading
the script and she woke him up and was
like I'm gonna do this this is my I'm
gonna be in this so she auditioned for
it it was of course just a goddess among
men because she's so good she was
incredible especially in some of the
tenser moments specifically her having
chuckles was so stressful but so good
I'll see you seeing a horror film in
theaters the audience is like reacting
to things like screaming or like Joel
Joel tea or you know like making like a
remark in the back that's supposed to be
funny to kind of relieve everyone
because you make jokes when you're
scared
there was nothing in this theatre it was
dead silent and the tension you could
just cut it with a knife who's everyone
was just so stressed you could feel
people breathing around she knew but
that's about it that's like that's a
good sign of a good scary film I don't
know that I would call this horror but I
guess that's what it is it was felt more
thriller though there were some scary
elements to it but back to acting John
was oh good and just loveable it was
like seeing Jim from the office but like
more rugged and more invested but the
best thing for me though is the children
I love seeing a film with good child
actors and these kids were stellar
specifically the little girl in the film
I don't know if she actually is but she
plays a deaf character and she blew me
away her ability to cry and look super
super invested and just my god her being
a deaf character added a lot because you
assumed that in the beginning they're
using sign language and you assumed
they're a stronger family unit in this
world because they had to learn
language before the fact we started off
the movie and it's only been 87 days
since the monsters showed up and I
really liked that in the film they go
from like 87 days to like 200 days like
400 days and you can't you see what's
changing it's one of those films it's
not like there's a beginning middle and
end it's not like a romantic comedy it's
just them living their lives so there's
no like obviously there's conflicts but
there's no like you know main conflict
of the film that gets resolved it's very
much just them living their lives and
you know terrifying horror what a blast
it's that good good stress that you just
want out of a film this is what I
thought about Dunkirk it's one that's a
good example I'm like this that looks
good it looks like it's gonna be a good
movie but it's just it's just gonna be
two hours of absolute stress non-stop
stress the entire time whereas this was
that it was non-stop stress but it was
so like oh like that good like gets in
your bones you feel it so I have four
pages of notes really loosely sprawled
out here and I'm just gonna read all of
the times that I felt stressed and felt
the need to write something down mm-hmm
here we go holy
so tense my jaw is open wide after the
first incident it's so stressful uh-huh
what scary oh my god the baby so
stressed Oh baby no I'm so stressed I am
so so stressed that's the
monsters I will talk about you get to
see them fully and I like the design I
think they were solid I know that's like
a very touchy subject for a lot of
horror films or thriller films and signs
being an example of that but I I really
enjoyed seeing the monster and I enjoyed
how they move very fast so I enjoyed
seeing them kind of in the beginning and
then you get a real real good look at
him as the movie goes on it righted me
of a movie that I just watch on Netflix
it's a Netflix
or film was called the ritual which I
just thought was so killer so good and
it's another one where you got to really
see the monster up close and personal
and like very details and I think that
that's really fun if it's a good looking
monster which in this case it was so I
think the story was really well paced
between them living their lives them
just doing like real life like hey
I'm doing family activities I'm playing
Monopoly okay I'm cooking I'm having a
child just normal everyday thanks they
also cut it really well with scary
things and big events with the monsters
it's really well paced if you don't love
me at my Devil Wears Prada you don't
deserve me at my a quiet place means so
breath of it it's not gonna age well
there were a couple hearts that we're a
little like oh that could be a hole in
the story you find out that there's a
weakness to the monster and I thought
that it was a very obvious thing not in
the way that it was explored through the
family but in a way that like these
monsters are plaguing the world right
now you would think that somebody would
have thought of the solution it's pretty
obvious so that was a weird thing I also
thought that the first incident that I
spoke of earlier without giving anything
away something bad happens and it was
pretty avoidable so it definitely
furthered the plot but it felt like we
probably gonna couldn't let that not
happen but I mean they needed it for the
story so I mean it made sense but yeah
one thing I count to be a little weird
is an emily Blunt's character you know
400 days in still has blonde hair that
you can tell has been colored so I mean
I don't know take time for yourself just
was a little weird but like you're
dyeing your hair blonde I don't know
that shouldn't have bothered me I don't
know why it did what it did overall
though the story was incredibly engaging
super well-written and these actors just
took a really solid story and just
really pushed it over the edge it was so
engaging so thrilling
keep doing this with my hands I really
wish that it didn't cut off where it cut
off I just wanted more I wanted to watch
more of it I would absolutely recommend
seeing this film it was so good and even
if you don't love horror it's just on
the line of thriller slash horror I
would still say that if if you're not a
fan of horror that you would be okay
with this it's gonna be a thrilling
night that you would truly be okay with
it it's so good and it's definitely
gonna keep me thinking for a long while
I loved the concept I loved how far they
took the concept and I just I totally
recommend this film I'm so so good thank
you so much for watching
wonder how many times I said good and
thrilling in that thanks for watching I
really appreciate it I will see you all
next week
[Music]